Hey.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, all right, cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, good.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so I'm keenly aware that because of Horace's ties, especially some of his merchanting, that
[SPEAKER_01]: That the offer, as where we left off, the offer of portage to the Sea Princes would be alluring, but I need to tread a little bit carefully with Horace, at least, because he's going to know what that means, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, it's not the collapse of Scant, but it is going to rival Scant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that what you said?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I think the thing is that what you would be offering to the Sea Principalities, if you wanted to use
[SPEAKER_00]: Dean and Naree is basically no taxes, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And their investment, well, their investment to re-fortify and partially, I mean, be part of rebuilding
[SPEAKER_01]: So here's the deal, though.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, this is an important thing, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: The Sea Principalities have lots of money.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lots of money.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And a underdeveloped country like Idee...
[SPEAKER_00]: Subtitles by the Amara.org community
[SPEAKER_00]: Are not that scary.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, they're not nearly as scary as Keoland, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, they're a bit of a paper tiger.
[SPEAKER_01]: But they've got troops.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're a paper tiger.
[SPEAKER_00]: Idee is kind of a paper mouse, is the problem, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Especially after we got wiped out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Idee lost a huge part of our population, which used to serve in our levees.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then begun how to fight in the name of the Iron League and 4AD and now we don't have that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, you know, they're not nearly as rich as Irongate or Onwal.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're very exposed, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But the one thing that the sea principalities are very good at, they have two things that they're very good at.
[SPEAKER_00]: They've got a very good navy and they really know how to build.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, the deal is this.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're not going to attack the South Province.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, of course not.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're not going to war with the South Province.
[SPEAKER_00]: What they would do is fortify a port and give you a half-orc, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Give what?
[SPEAKER_00]: Give you a half-orc for their troubles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I'd like maybe some money to hire mercenaries.
[SPEAKER_01]: That would be awfully nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, yeah, I mean, that would be part of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, definitely, if they fortified a place, they would want to put mercenaries there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if you said, we'll give you this and blah, blah, blah.
[SPEAKER_00]: But really what it is, is they would literally, I mean, Jamis basically told Karmirg he had to leave.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because of what he did, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: He was banned from Monmurg for one year, and he was told he could never be a citizen of the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And so, if Jamis says to Karmirg,
[SPEAKER_00]: You go help these guys and build a port.
[SPEAKER_00]: Build a port for us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Make this place a place for Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll be a citizen.
[SPEAKER_01]: That might work.
[SPEAKER_01]: Except for I do need Karmirg in the field.
[SPEAKER_01]: But what I also feel like is if we had mercenaries, so I, what my thoughts are is that
[SPEAKER_01]: If they help rebuild the city of Naree, they fortify the city of Naree, they provide some mercenary forces to defend the city of Naree, that is going to give a lot of hope.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think if you can help rebuild Naree, you're going to rebuild the heart of kind of like the people that are left.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if the people that are left see that their city is being rebuilt and defended, they may be more likely to go out and take the field, because they might not feel like they have to, you know, get the hell out of, you know, Naree and just leave and flee.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus, I think you said to me, if that's accurate, that we got, even though the hill tribe's kind of deserted...
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe not deserted, just kind of left after Karmirg left.
[SPEAKER_01]: At the same time, you said we're getting hill folk refugees from the Iron Hills, like hill barbarians.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they're coming into Idee because they're being pushed out, and so we need to channel those guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so, I mean, really, the thing is, is that, you know, Naree right now, I mean, Idee right now is like a wild land.
[SPEAKER_00]: And truthfully, stabilizing the city would be a huge thing for Anlauf Ogmotton.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, so that's kind of what I'm thinking, that I gotta sell trade rights or, you know, lifetime or permanent, you know, portage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, at the same time, I mean, like, D still has to be able to make money.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, if they don't make it through taxes, they can still trade, correct?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I'm not sure if I understand the fiscal stuff of that as much.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, D is, from what you understand, a very, very egregarian place.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, there is trade that could happen there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And actually, I think that this is kind of in your evil mind.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you had the backing of the Sea Princes...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not evil.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I know, but you have an evil mind, as all good people have.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know that actually if the Sea Princes were backing a port in Naree, it would rival Scant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, and I'm kind of irritated that Scant and the great, you know, Irongate seem, you know, fine with maybe not letting, you know, letting the D be in question.
[SPEAKER_00]: So this is a long-term play, but I mean the truth is this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's say 10 years down the line you fortify Naree, okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: Things stabilize.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Sea Princes only trade out of that port.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this goes down to the Lindor Isles.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, you know, here's another thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: You say, Onwal and Irongate don't get to trade in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: They have to trade through Naree.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Think of the money.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I was going to say, that's going to make the D more prominent, because like you said, they were always a little bit of the red-headed stepchild in the Alliance.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it will extend the power of the C principalities quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so... Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what I learned from Horus, because what I was thinking about is trying to get...
[SPEAKER_01]: More for less from the Sea Princes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I was hoping that possibly the Sea Princes would be worried about the South Province getting Naree and themselves rebuilding it and, you know, ten years down the road, putting a force into the Azure Sea.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it seems that Horus doesn't think that that's very likely and or the South Province or the Herzog of the South Province doesn't seem to be that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, by the way, and I'm going to say this, the sea principalities care more about the influence of Onwal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which they don't really care about all that much than the Great Kingdom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: They just want to see money flow.
[SPEAKER_00]: They feel no threat from the Great Kingdom.
[SPEAKER_00]: The only threat they feel from Onwal is taxation between the two of their economies.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now you said that the big cities were
[SPEAKER_01]: Irongate, and Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Monmurg, Greyhawk, and then Irongate are like the big trading cities, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, my only thing is, can I entreat, when I entreat with the Sea Princes, can I just entreat with like, through Jamis, with like Prince Jeon of Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you know that Jamis is the main counselor of Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: See, because I have a severe distaste for any of the poor Toli, the Toli, you know, Suli kind of stuff going on, and I'd really rather not, I don't think that I can introduce.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, poor Toli is not nearly the center of trade that Monmurg is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, of course, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just wondering if, like, I mean, the alliance would, I'd prefer to be between Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely you would.
[SPEAKER_00]: And by the way, that's where the money is.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you read my thing, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I did.
[SPEAKER_00]: I did.
[SPEAKER_00]: Monmurg is like, by the way, just full of wealth.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's crazy.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I want to remember that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You remember that when I picked some local variant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not necessarily something that's just coming in off the docks or like, you know, that they have access to.
[SPEAKER_01]: So whatever the wine or mead or local liqueur that I'm bringing over for Jamis, I'd like it to be a little bit unique.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So just something that he's not going to easily, like, you know, be able to get his hands on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Preferably if it's something that he likes, like if it's a wine, that's great.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I'll go over unique instead of his preference in taste.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, expensive, and actually something, what you probably think is the best you could do is something elven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because that would be unique.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, now, where are the elves and small enclaves?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I don't really know much about any elves over in the iron realm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you actually really do, because you are an elf, and there is the Kingdom of Selene.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which is, uh, to... That's north, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's to the... From the Irongate.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, well, no, no, no, it's way to the west of the Irongate stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's actually on the border of Keoland, the eastern border of Keoland.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so that would have been maybe when we were up going to Greyhawk City and getting the army, basically, if I'm packing around, like, some of that stuff left over.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then, uh, Sundee has elves as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: If I can get a Sundee variant, that would be good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: You could probably find something from there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then the Dreadwood has a lot of elves in it, from what you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is the Dreadward in our region?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like South Province, Iron League, Sundee?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's to the west of Keoland and north of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, but it's way to the west.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you ever travel there?
[SPEAKER_01]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did our group ever travel there to Keoland?
[SPEAKER_01]: I know we were in the Pomarge.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you never went to Keoland, actually.
[SPEAKER_00]: What you did was you...
[SPEAKER_00]: Briefly went through Gradsul, but mainly you went through the Pumarch and then up into Greyhawk and over.
[SPEAKER_01]: Through Nairon.
[SPEAKER_01]: We had ventured down into the Scarlet Brotherhood territory, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I mean... Was it Hempoland?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I mean, you guys traveled up into the North Province, all over that place, and then, I mean, you've traveled all over Greyhawk, really.
[SPEAKER_00]: Didn't spend a lot of time in Keoland.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't think so.
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't remember them very much.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I do have some knowledge of the monks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are they monks in the Scarlet Brotherhood?
[SPEAKER_01]: The Suel in that peninsula that's south of the Irongate?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the ones you were attacked by were Suel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And did we have, because I haven't had a chance to read if you were able to respond, do I know much about them other than we were attacked?
[SPEAKER_01]: I remember they'd hunt Mola Land, which is south of the Scarlet Brotherhood, that peninsula.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've got to go over the Tilva Straits.
[SPEAKER_01]: I remember we had to go there to cure Gouges.
[SPEAKER_01]: He had failed that save on like a rare poison or something, or he needed a rare plant to help cure his, you know, I don't know, his...
[SPEAKER_00]: Condition.
[SPEAKER_00]: His condition.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that was why we were traveling to hemp on the land, period, correct?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then, I'm still, I'm kind of blank.
[SPEAKER_01]: I remember running into, you know, the Scarlet Brotherhood.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just don't remember how much I would know of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if that was...
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you know the monks that you ran into were Suel, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But they were actually a very kind of... Suel or Roy is very strange, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not sure if I actually like them.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I want to know more about their magic, but I have a
[SPEAKER_00]: So, historically, they're known to be kind of a race that ruled a great empire that was destroyed about a thousand years ago in what was called the Twin Cataclysms, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, and that's where the Sea of Dust was formed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, and then they fled.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you had the Orderians or something?
[SPEAKER_01]: You had the Orderians.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oeridians, the Oeridians, actually, which are the major race in the Flanness.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, they're the ones that, uh, the Great Kingdom is ruled by Oeridians.
[SPEAKER_00]: And actually, you know, a lot of Oeridians, Oeridians are all over the place, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, they kind of,
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_00]: Flannish is the Irish, the Oeridians as the Vikings, and then the Suel as the Normans.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or Romans, actually.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're more like Romans because they were very sophisticated, very much magical in a way.
[SPEAKER_00]: And even though the race of Suel is small, when they have centuries of power, they're very powerful.
Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, for example, Port Toli is kind of a mixture of Suel and Iridium, but the ruling class is Suel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you hear me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I can.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay, good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's what I was known to.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so, are the Suel, like, so with magic as an elf and as a wizard, do I have a sense for...
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there any, like, are the Suel a little bit more of a magical people, or the Oeridians, or do I have a sense of that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you know the history as an elf.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not the deep history, and actually this is something that, you know, if you research you can find this out, but the story is that the Suel were the first men that elves found.
[SPEAKER_00]: Way back, you know, thousands of years ago, and they were called the Suel back then, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So the gray elves that came to the world found the Suel and they taught them magic, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And the elves, you know, basically dallied with them for a thousand years and spent time educating these
[SPEAKER_00]: Humans, to be magic users, and taught them magic, and then they traveled on, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the SU-EL became the Suel, and they became powerful in their own way, and they forgot the elves.
[SPEAKER_00]: They didn't forget them.
[SPEAKER_00]: They always knew who they were, but their influence with the elves became less and less.
[SPEAKER_00]: And as the elves moved on through the Flanness, they like, you know, traveled through the lands.
[SPEAKER_00]: The SU-EL became the Suel and became very powerful with magic, but in their own way.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they kind of forgot the...
[SPEAKER_00]: Warnings that the elves gave them about magic.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then the Grey Elves, the inheritor, well, the offspring of the Grey Elves kind of became...
[SPEAKER_00]: The High Elves.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which is for me.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're a High Elf.
[SPEAKER_00]: You were born on this...
[SPEAKER_00]: So the difference between a Grey Elf and a High Elf is a Grey Elf came from Avandor, which is Elven Heaven.
[SPEAKER_00]: And a High Elf was born on this planet, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, the High Elves worked with the Suel for a while, but there was some conflict in the ancient past.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, no, I remember that, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in fact, at one point, the Drow corrupted the Suel
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: To fight against the High Elves.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there was a war between them.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the Crystal Mist Mountains.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now...
[SPEAKER_01]: So... Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: So tell me this, now I'm jumping forward again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is the Sea Princes, if Port Toli or the ruling family in Port Toli is Suel, would I know what are the other Sea Princes?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, are they Suel or Oeridian?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, the...
[SPEAKER_00]: Prince of Port Toli is Suel, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: All of the princes of the Outer Islands are Oeridians.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, okay, so it's just Toli as one of the sea princes, and there's five sea princes?
[SPEAKER_00]: There are five sea princes, but there are two plars.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the plars are both Suel.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there are three major ancient families in the sea principalities, which are Suel.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there are four major Oeridian families, which are the princes, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And the Outer Islands, the princes of the sea principalities, are the sailors and traders.
[SPEAKER_01]: And those are the Oeridians.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's like Flotsam, Jetsam.
[SPEAKER_00]: Flotsam, Jetsam, what's the other one?
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't remember.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fairwind, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: So those are the four, you know, Oeridian princes.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's one Toli prince called Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then...
[SPEAKER_00]: There is the duchy of... God, what is that called?
[SPEAKER_00]: Berghof?
[SPEAKER_00]: Berghof.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then the... And then you've got Keoland and Yeomanry.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, Keoland is a huge nation, but then there is the plar of the north, which is the plar of Westkeep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and West Keep is on the borderland with southern Keoland, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: You've got Kool, or the marshes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kool is the town.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Hool Marshes.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Hool Marshes, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, the Hool Marshes.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, think about Westkeep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Westkeep is kind of isolated, and what's funny is Keoland has tried to attack Westkeep in the past and failed because the Hool Marshes are very dangerous.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in fact, Keoland has, like, tried to...
[SPEAKER_00]: There's some weirdness there.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like, the Hull Marshes were once part of Keoland, but that's... it's been in question for hundreds of years, exactly, what their influence is over there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I think I have my plan.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd like to spend the rest of the voyage exploring Horace's knowledge of, like,
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, I still don't understand if the Sea Barons, especially if they were an offshoot of the Sea Princess, if the Sea Barons represent any kind of a threat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I'd like to, I'm trying to figure out if I could use that as any kind of a leverage, because a pack made with a D could develop into a pack made with some D, and that could develop into preventing or at least putting a port on southern,
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, the truth is, is the Sea Barrens are a conflict because they're raiders.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, they just, they, they rape trade.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, kind of, but really what's happened is the Sea Barrens have kind of become, you know, for the Great Kingdom, letters of mark, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So they were kind of bribed by the Great Kingdom to disrupt this trade that they don't really have a part of.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, what they are, are pirates that take bribes from the nobles of the Great Kingdom.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, and so my thought is that any positions, if the Sea Princes wanted to lock the Sea Barons out of the Azure Sea, it would be by being able to dominate the Straits of Tilva.
[SPEAKER_00]: I agree.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does that make sense?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's one of the things, like you said, it's the long game.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if it gets the Sea Princes invested in Idee, if Anlauf Ogmotton...
[SPEAKER_00]: So by the way, I would ask you to roll a 20-sided die, but I'm going to give you the long and short of it because I think your character's smart enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is the long game, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because the way that...
[SPEAKER_00]: And you would have to convince somebody of this.
[SPEAKER_00]: The way it is, is that you probably have a feeling that the Sea Princes would rather pay bribes more than the Great Kingdom could to let trade go through.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, in truth,
[SPEAKER_00]: The Sea Princes basically let Unwall feel that heat from the Sea Barons.
[SPEAKER_00]: If there is actually a port in a D, maybe they would be interested in what you're saying.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, right, because they would have to be invested in even the possibility of blocking out the sea barons and not just paying them off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, and actually probably what would happen is that they, because they have common background, they would pay them off and actually kind of try and enlist them against the Great Kingdom.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, right, which would be awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess then that brings us back to Gouge and his Letters of Mark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I have any suspicion that that would be the Sea Prince's allowing him to fly a seabaron flag and ravage scant trading?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, this is kind of the weird part of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um...
[SPEAKER_00]: If that was the case, why did Gouge go back to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_00]: Why is he not plying the seas between here and at Thee?
[SPEAKER_00]: It would seem more likely that Gouge would deal with Amoth and Sulborn and try and save... That's true.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's true, because then he would want to operate out of Naree.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly, because those waters are much easier than the waters that are around Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is what is confusing to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, so he's being tasked by the Sea Princes, or at least by Monmurg, with a letter of marque to prey on other shipping.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which would be either possibly Keoland,
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're worried something's happening closer to home in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or there's fighting going on between the Sea Princes and he's a cutout to sort of prey upon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like there's infighting and Jamis needs him there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then the question is, is when we land,
[SPEAKER_01]: Has, uh, Horst has never been to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, he's been to Monmurg, but he's never been to Monmurg with us, has he?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, never.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because now what I'm wondering is, like, do I need to have somebody check?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I have a rogue on my employment?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, did I send him ahead?
[SPEAKER_01]: I know we talked about it vaguely, or if not, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you don't.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have contacts in the city.
[SPEAKER_00]: That you know and Ferd is actually where you want to go and meet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm just not sure if I want to go to Ferd's like immediately or if I want to try to see or scout Ferd's out like clandestinely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Totally, I understand that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I might want to just take a nondescript room in the foreign quarter and kind of maybe have Horace go scout out Ferd's.
[SPEAKER_01]: I talked to Horace about that on the trip, about my intention to maybe just get a nondescript room in the foreign quarter, but I described to him Ferds, and I make sure, I mean, he knows, he knows what Gouge looks like, he knows what Karmirg looks like.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he agrees to be your, you know, your scout, your cutout for this.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, you know, he will even contact them if you need...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you guys travel, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we have eight minutes left.
[SPEAKER_01]: How come we're not doing this on the phone?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because I hate to say it, Zoom is easier than holding a phone up to my ear.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you don't have, like, earbuds or anything?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I hate that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: We can do that later, but I want to get Roll20 working, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, yeah, no, I need to get it working.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so as far as for roll 20, it almost looks like, remember when I asked you to reinstall, so I was back in, I don't know what's wrong with me not seeing the full audio functions, I can still double check that, but I was not able to open up the stuff that you downloaded from my sheet.
[SPEAKER_01]: I did see it.
[SPEAKER_01]: My mistake on my end was that I wasn't hitting
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to email you all of the character sheet stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll take care of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: But whatever the case...
[SPEAKER_00]: You and Horace sail, having these conversations.
[SPEAKER_00]: And by the way, you know, if there are details you want to know about, that's fine, as far as he knows.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys sail towards Monmurg, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But when you're about a week outside of Monmurg,
[SPEAKER_00]: On your own Wallian ship, a couple of Keoland man o' wars sail up beside you and signal your ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And actually make your ship stop and they board.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, what do you want to do during this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, can Keoland Man O' Wars outrun us if we wanted to run?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or are you saying that our captain goes ahead and pulls over and... Well, I mean, actually the captain could try, but for some reason he doesn't.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to be totally neutral.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, anything that I've got, I believe, is from a D. I did ask if I could have a captain's flag from like, you know, or like a ship's flag from the whatever, but I stick that underneath the floorboard.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's yours.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're going to use that later if you need to, but you're not going to use that right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'm not going to use that right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'll just be, you know, from a D, from Scant.
[SPEAKER_01]: They don't have any historic problems other than, like, if Keoland's just tried to intercept shipping and thwart, again, the sea princess.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I mean, yeah, I'll just mind my business.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll mind my P's and Q's.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just a traveler, you know, living in the nice quarters.
[SPEAKER_01]: Going to Monmurg, traveling from Scant.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, Horace goes up and says, I'm going to see what's going on.
[SPEAKER_00]: This seems very strange to me, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And he goes up on deck.
[SPEAKER_00]: He comes back in about 30 minutes and says, We're being redirected towards Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that a seaport in Keoland?
[SPEAKER_00]: He says to you, it's a shithole, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: A tiny island off the coast of Selenmor, which is a forgotten province in Keoland.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no idea why this is happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it an island province?
[SPEAKER_00]: Selenmor is a large province, but it's basically...
[SPEAKER_00]: A land of... a cursed land.
[SPEAKER_00]: A land of... lycanthropy and necromancy.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no idea why we'd be going there.
[SPEAKER_01]: What was your impression of the captain?
[SPEAKER_01]: Was he equally as surprised as you?
[SPEAKER_00]: The captain was surprised, but he was cowed.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no idea why, because this ship is twice as fast as anything that Keoland
[SPEAKER_00]: Can put to sea.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we could outrun the man of wars if we...
[SPEAKER_01]: Easily.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no idea what's happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need you and your equipment and gear.
[SPEAKER_01]: We might have to persuade the captain.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are they leaving any kind of a force on board here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many?
[SPEAKER_00]: Ten men.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your appraisal of those men?
[SPEAKER_00]: I would say they're fine Marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're warriors.
[SPEAKER_00]: They can fight.
[SPEAKER_00]: They could probably take the crew, but you and I, we have some influence.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's concerning to me, however, is the captain has no want to fight.
[SPEAKER_01]: We may have to
[SPEAKER_01]: But there was no duplicity in the captain.
[SPEAKER_01]: He said he was confused.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is he perhaps compromised?
[SPEAKER_00]: You mean bribe?
[SPEAKER_00]: I could not tell that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think he was generally feared.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll be honest.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's been rumors among the crew.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ships have been going down for no reason when they travel to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was the warning from these Keogh men-of-war captains.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they're going to bring us this shithole Salamor to protect us?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's their excuse.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's our excuse.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want the men armed to the best of your ability, even if it's just with pins and knives.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we are not going to Salomar.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do not have the time for this.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we have to kill the ten men and make a run for it, we will.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you able to persuade the First Maid if we must remove the captain?
[SPEAKER_00]: It'll cost money.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have a minute and a half left.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to play tomorrow?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: What time?
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's do maybe about 8 o'clock again or 7.30.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what I'll try to do is you try to see on your end.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was able to log in.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got your invite.
[SPEAKER_01]: I saw Journey of the Stone.
[SPEAKER_01]: See if you can load me up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to try to figure out the sound thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have like a practice thing that I hadn't really run through before.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm hoping maybe that they have like a testing thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: 8 p.m. tomorrow, let's play.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You try to work it out on your end, and let's see what happens.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sounds good.
[SPEAKER_01]: And don't forget to send me just those PDFs and emails, just standard email.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Talk to you later.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bye.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bye-bye.